[Music]
sometimes it can be hard to tell who's
cheating in a game other times it could
be so obvious you end up wondering what
the hell were they thinking and the
worst part about obvious cheaters is
that they often get caught and still
lose usually more than once too but
before we get into that make sure you
are subscribed to the score esports that
way you'll never miss a video just like
this one and with that let's get into
the top 10 cheaters who still lost
at number 10 we have faze jarvis and his
ill-conceived attempt to uh
educate his viewers you know in case
they didn't know what a fortnight aimbot
looks like
i don't miss a shot
i don't miss a shot bro yo we're correct
jarvis uploaded his exploits to youtube
which then resulted in a lifetime ban
from fortnite now to his credit jarvis
did apologize profusely but as they say
you can't put toothpaste back in the
tube
you know it's obvious that i made a
massive mistake and of course i would
never think about doing anything like
this again you know when i was making
those videos i never thought about the
consequence
the bizarre case of a mid-match
switcheroo is ninth on our list
involving virtus pro and ad finnum at
the 2016 european qualifier grand finals
for the summit 5 dota 2 tournament hey
did you guys know that virtus pro is
going to the summit 5 well that's
because they're not they cheat one of
vp's players aloha dance ran into some
connectivity problems during the match
ad finnham were kind enough to lend vp
their allotted pause time to get aloha
back into the game what vp did instead
though was substitute aloha for vegas
squadrons no one who proceeded to help
bp win the match three to two and secure
the last remaining summit slot they step
in they try to get g
they silence them up they make their
move there's the swap back by spartan
but yoku has another chrono waiting for
him and that will be the game
congratulations virtus pro it wasn't
until a reddit user d dropped pointed
out some in-game inconsistencies that
the switch was discovered by bts
everyone apologized but it was just too
little too late an ad finnham replaced
vp in the summer five lan finals
our eighth entry comes from a tune of
team thunder predator and his very
obvious use of mouse macro during the
ti8 south american qualifier a concerned
reddit user pointed out that some of the
tunes moves shouldn't even be possible
at the rate he was executing them
oh boy tires bottom towers getting hit
the post got the admin's attention and
after reviewing the evidence thunder
predators were disqualified from the
tournament
could there be anything more
embarrassing than getting banned
mid-match yeah and we're going to see
them you know they need to start getting
some of that
some more oh
[Music]
emilio our pick for the seventh spot on
this list found out the answer to that
question during the frag bite masters
online qualifier match against
hellraisers he's out in the russian
wilderness just sniping
did emilio just get back banned
what
what emilio initially tried to blame the
whole thing on a friend clara who was
supposedly cheating using one of
emilio's other accounts but his team
were unable to find any proof of that in
the 48-hour window they had with valve
surprising absolutely no one team
property then kicked emilio and he was
also banned from all future frag by
events
the sixth spot on our list goes to azubu
frost and their keen interest in
anything but their own screens during a
quarterfinals match against tsm at the
league of legends season 2 world
championship playoffs that's going to
keep being the case those targets will
take a lot of damage in fights dyrus
gets the power fist or rather the rocket
grab to go right through the cape
they're just making it out beautiful
ward placement coming from azubu frost
and like i said it's completely
aggressive they want to get every single
kill that they can azubu frost wandering
eyes and uncannily fast reactions to
plays they shouldn't have been able to
see tip the opposing team and the
community after the fact that there was
something off one of the guys from azubu
frost you can even see in the video he
looked at the minimap of tsm
for like one second or so now you may be
thinking like oh maybe he just looked
away and maybe he did not look at the
minimap but what's very very fishy is
after he looked at the minimap a few
seconds later he pings
that tsm is right in there tsm is coming
to the top
and how the hell did he know that it's
like
he had no vision of it and he pinged so
i think that azuba frost actually
cheated taking advantage of the
audience's view of the mini-map cost
azubu 30 000
after a riot investigation concluded
that screen peaking was indeed cheating
we roll into number five now with an
entry from the world of e-cycling
virtual cyclist and champion cameron
jeffers really wanted the best bike
zwift had to offer the tron model but
chose to do virtually nothing to get it
so you know this person logged into my
account used an ample simulator which i
don't know exactly how they work because
i've never used one myself um so i can't
honestly tell you completely uh
accurately but i think it's something
some sort of software on on your
computer
and you can essentially just put in like
a power value for example like 400 watts
click enter and your avatar within the
game will just sit at 400 watts about
like you having to pedal jeff's choice
to not put the pedal to the metal
ultimately cost him 250 pounds in fines
and resulted in a six month suspension
from the esports
cheating at a world's finals of any game
takes some serious balls which is what
earns greg empire 77 the fourth spot on
our list you have to play here live on a
stage actually a really sick stage i
have to say but in front of a crowd like
that's extra pressure on your shoulders
knowing like you said earlier on a
chance in that one slight misstep of a
play one tile over could lose you an
entire match at the red bull emio world
finals of 2019 the clash royale pro was
caught communicating with his manager
mid-match using a pair of earbuds he
wore underneath his headset not that it
helped him much either because gregg
empire 77 still lost the set three to
one now to be fair once the infraction
was discovered greg didn't try to deny
the allegations and was disqualified
from the tournament as a result
you know we had to coming in at number
three is forsaken who will basically
never live down his blatant cheating
attempt at extremes land zowie asia
2018. the event and it's going to be a b
split in towards the bomb site so they
react accordingly for staple would pop
flash into maine and he's gonna get
three frags crazy guy fog and jason all
are dropping he'll get the fourth as
well great work from forsaken now if for
some reason you don't know the story
optic india's match versus revolution
bien showcase forsaken's incredible
talent for cheating his infamous
word.exe file that contained the cheats
was quickly discovered by admins and
gave us the memes we all know and love
what a god bro who's the balls to do
that on land i know
i need to
as for forsaken himself he was slapped
with a five-year ban from participating
in anything esports related after
putting a pretty huge dent in indian cs
go and was basically never seen or heard
from again guess there's always that one
guy who ruins it for everyone
dream is one of the biggest minecraft
streamers out there but it's his
controversial speed run that lands him
in the second spot on our list in
october of 2020 dreams submitted a time
for the any percent random seed
glitchless category in which he had to
kill the ender dragon in a randomly
seeded world now to do that he needed
ender pearls the time dream submitted
made him the world's sixth fastest
player in this category but speedrun.com
mods as well as a few prominent
youtubers weren't so sure it was legit
dream just had a few too many ender
pearls compared to what rng should have
yielded now this really isn't looking
too good for dream biasing in favor of
him giving very favorable circumstances
and assuming the best the odds for all
this happening is still around 1 in 678
trillion well that is before we account
for p hacking basically saying let's be
generous and say there are 90 ways to
investigate two types of rng if someone
malicious was looking to cherry-pick
data then they would just choose the
most unlikely one out of the 90. so
since we'd want to correct for this
potential bias we divide 678 trillion by
90 and get a value of 1 in 7 trillion
which as you may notice is still a
ridiculously large number following an
investigation into the matter dreams
record was taken off the leaderboards
dream denied any wrongdoing and even
attempted to bring in a harvard trained
astrophysicist to back him up but
eventually admitted that he did actually
cheat he just didn't realize that he had
csgo's biggest cheating scandal involved
as many as 37 people but it's heroics
former coach london that takes the top
spot on our list while he didn't cheat
in the traditional sense of the word he
and other cs go coaches took advantage
of a bug that allowed them to use the
spectator tool to reveal parts of the
map and pass the info on to their team
i've got this game loaded up it's heroic
versus astralis it's the match where
hunden for the first 10 rounds
uh
had a coach camera or had a camera and
freak him on banana hunden and the rest
of the implicated coaches were banned by
esic for anywhere from 4 to 36 months
and he was also suspended by heroic
hunden wasn't fired though the malign
coach took the blame entirely upon his
own shoulders saying the team knew
nothing about the bug at the time of the
incident and so heroic were willing to
give the relationship another go
unfortunately there must have been some
serious trust issues and bad blood in
the aftermath of the cheating scandal as
hunden allegedly leaked sensitive stress
to one of the team's competitors and
also changed his original story alleging
that the players did know about the
spectator bug after all not surprisingly
heroic pursued legal action against
hundred and released him from the org
pretty soon afterwards
well those were some sorry cheaters that
still lost the game they were cheating
in do you guys know of any better
examples out there there's a good chance
you do if so let us know also let us
know what you want to see next on the
channel thanks for watching and i'll see
you all in the next one
hey just why did i reload what the [ __ ]
oh my god i'm stupid the other day
i played the other day with rock and he
got that and now i have it i don't i
don't know what's why it's weird
wait what the [ __ ]
clara
hold on clara give me one